it's time for roses and rose hey you
guys hi hi hello I have missed you guys
so much i'm lauren zima
and we are here to talk about the
Bachelorette baby yes Hanabi it is one
month from today that we will be basking
in the morning after glow of the season
premiere of Hanna Brown's Bachelorette
this is season 15 Oh The Bachelor are
you guys oh my god so of course we took
a little roses and roses a break a
little pause after quoting Underwood
season to breathe to recalibrate but
here's the thing I can only go so long
without missing my favorite franchise so
today look at this I have a bottle of
Rose they have never had one of these on
the show before and I'm not showing you
the brand because they don't sponsor us
their loss there are many their travels
so portable I love it I love it Rose a
on the go that's what I need in my life
because I am on the girl that could have
been more but no right we are off the
cuff today that was awesome because it's
been so difficult to be without the
Bachelorette I'm gonna need a big ol
drink to soothe myself
Wow I have missed you guys so much
please just tell me how you've been in
the comments literally how are you are
you okay are you excited for Hannah
Brown season of The Bachelorette awesome
I am too so every week from now until
Hanna's season we will do a new episode
of roses and rosy on Tuesdays yes roses
and Tuesday before we've been doing this
show and putting it up on Tuesdays for
years now I can't wear that I apologize
anyway so this week we are going to do
one of my favorite things
bachelor news you can booze but again
we're gonna be four episodes up till the
premiere and we're gonna do some fun EPS
in there the most dramatic Bachelorette
moments ever so leave your suggestions
in the comments and we are going to go
back through every single Bachelorette
season and how it ended plus of course
more bachelor news we won't miss down
let's begin first of all we got our
first promo we are just going to talk
through it
first of all I love this song giving me
First Wives Club vibes of course we do
not own Hannah nobody does she owns
herself and she is in the woods why we
don't know but she's got her crown on oh
wait you know she doesn't she's taking
it off
goodbye crap why did she throw it away I
have to say what put in my pocket or
something I would keep it leave it in
your rear-view mirror as you descend
down the hill oh she's taking off the
sash she is not a beauty queen anymore
still beautiful different oh she is
pooping roses and she's taking off her
skirt goodbye skirts I'm and a rubber
bumpers are great to dance in and
they're still sexy I'm looking at the
camera thank you know her I thought I
did oh I've got to think again I got to
think again Hannah be the Bachelorette
in a jumpsuit cap sleeve oh man I love
this promo you guys what did you think
of it ranks is maybe my favorite
Bachelorette promo of all time song
selection super fun
Hannah's outfit is super glam and there
was a reveal fit by skirt hello woman of
today I like that were shedding the
beauty-queen image of Hannah because it
was so much a part of her story line on
Colton season and I'm over it
I think we'll still hear about it on her
season but she's clearly not going to be
marketed as a beauty queen she is moving
forward she is fighting fierce love
she's in the woods
she's fairytale princess where is she
love it
Hannah is sassy girl how'd you feel
tonight seeing Colton's oh that old man
I know that cuz they've interviewed her
a couple times now she speaks her mind
she says what she thinks
that's the same thing we loved Colton's
season of The Bachelor and a huge part
of that was that Colton storyline was
not all about who he was dumped by it
was about him being a virgin I think
it's gonna benefit for Hannah season
that her story is not going to be all
about her being dumped by Colton you
know did the math guys
is the furthest out from the final that
a bachelorette choice has ever been she
was number seven or something in terms
of when she actually left the show
because you got accounts of people who
self eliminated everybody on the gold
he's now like Heather so he and I was
seventh or something she wasn't even top
two three four like believe that if you
picked her at the end you would never
see the full person it's also the first
time that the Bachelorette he was a
little bit of a villain at some point
during our season remember in the
beginning we didn't love Hannah we were
all kind of Morris on Kalon side and
things are really taking a turn haven't
they are you saw board for Hannah's
Bachelorette I really promise guys I
think it's gonna be a really good season
so it's also the fifteenth season of The
Bachelorette the news is we're getting a
big bachelorette reunion yes almost
every single Bachelorette in the history
of the show
was brought to the mansion for a reunion
special that will air on May 6 I think
Jacy check me on that I shouldn't but we
saw photos from the behind the scenes of
the reunion including this picture from
creator Mike Fleiss of all the ladies in
a van and he said can you name them all
guys try to do it along with me
we're gonna go counterclockwise I think
no clockwise I'm starting with the woman
in the blue floral so I will try and
hopefully get everyone right Gillian
Ashley Becca Jojo
Kaitlyn Alli Trista Emily and
dianna Desiree I think I nailed that and
I will choose to myself drink it all the
few nailed it two more Bachelorette news
you can booze we have gotten some
behind-the-scenes photos from filming
and I always love to analyze the fast
shot we love that we get a mixture of
like warm and cold cozy looks love a
scarf moment and we had plenty so drink
for a scarf mmm
drink for a castle mm-hmm drinking for
another scarf god that's the same beanie
drink every time we see that beanie it
seems to be Hannah's favorite beanie
we're drinking for the beanie she's
wearing it a lot can we get her another
hat mm we're also getting a little
behind-the-scenes look of some of the
dates including my nightmare playing a
sport an actual sport participating on
the field of the court what is it in
basketball is it called a court it's
called a court Oh Hannah seems to be
playing basketball with the men
no thank you
what do you think would you guys want to
engage in a sport on a date it's just
not my thing
can we go why you say that's a sport
competitive games I don't care if I win
no win or lose you still have fun Wow
okay then another behind the scenes
picture no Castle no beautiful European
setting in the background and that is
kind of a sad background and also do we
really need another fence get her away
from that fence walk away Hannah go away
don't jump it don't climb it get away I
can't take any more fences guys no more
fences that movie Denzel Washington
Viola Davis was it called fences
no fences tear down that wall fence we
also got a behind-the-scenes picture of
the guys in the mansion and there is so
much to break down here first of all
very interesting for me to see the
production lighting I love a
behind-the-scenes moment those three
cameras lined up with a beautiful group
of soldiers in the army of bachelor
nation out to conquer the war of drama
and give us a win which would be an
amazing season figure out if it's real
or fake there's so much of it and it's
also large the bananas are so long
there's a watermelon and why would that
be there even as like a prop like a set
dressing nobody just has like a trout of
fruit at their house and a whole
watermelon there's a sad pineapple that
looks like it was knocked over it's
weird just stick with candles and roses
they are made of their fruit okay more
behind-the-scenes pictures and more
sports
oh god drink for all the sports this one
pana is participating again and look I
get it women I'm not saying we click
play sports I just don't like them
personally but I want to give Hannah
major props she seems to be doing roller
derby and look at those shorts they're
like a pleather a leather tight short
crop situation and she looks fit and
amazing props to Hannah cheers to that
concerned about those helmets though her
and this guy who looks a lot like Van
Hagen's is that just me do you see it do
you see it do you see it they both don't
seem to have their helmets on hearses
tilted back his is not clipped let's be
safe shall we they're playing all these
sports we also got a helicopter moment
Mike Fleiss said on the wings of love
Oh see know millions of love Oh God
do we have any idea see I don't even
know I know the song uh-huh on the wings
that love but who sang it Jeffrey
Osborne from 1982 perhaps my favorite
behind-the-scenes photo revealed was
Hannah and Chris Harrison on night one
and I just want to say not well like
what you're thinking I mean I look
everything looks good but Hannah is a
wow she looks unbelievable and I'm so
glad to see that her night one dress was
not a white wedding dress because Becca
Coover and and Rachel Lindsay both wore
white dresses on night one and I'm ready
for something new it's champagne II
shows little legs Sparkle what do you
guys think of Hannah's night one look
big loved it
big fan drink him to it massively into
its huge moment large success don't
drink every time I was a synonym for BAE
okay the show earlier than they have
ever done before released the
contestants online in photos the people
had a lot to say about including myself
the lighting was really bad guys I don't
know what was going on with these
pictures I almost think maybe these were
the pictures the contestants submitted
themselves and then the background was
photoshopped into this weird teal color
what do you guys think because the
lighting was just so inconsistent and
smeared on all of them and I know a lot
of former contestants have been like
please don't criticize our pictures I'm
just criticizing the production value
you know they could have made you guys
look better I think that probably all
these guys are better looking and more
fashionable than these pictures make
them appear to be right right right
sometimes I like to pick a potential
frontrunner just based on the pictures
did you guys do that and if so tell me
who you're into all right a couple this
stuck out for me purely based on their
photos at knowing where they are from
Connor he's from Dallas Dallas is such a
bachelor hub these days I just think
success comes from Dallas like Jojo and
Jordan live there Rachel and Bryan lived
there Hannah's from Alabama so I could
see you're vibing with a Dallas boy
Connor also sticking out
to me Garret P he is from Birmingham
Alabama same hometown as Hannah got a
great smile great hair to Jed from
Nashville I'm going so much off of
location but he's got nice arms too and
you know what I could see Hannah living
in Nashville one day it's the perfect
transition from Alabama to like the
south and Nashville's also a bachelor
hub Carly and Ivan live there Caitlin
and Shh people live there dudes - who
else who else Luke peep from Gainesville
Georgia you know Luke pal did well on
Jojo season so a Luke P could triumph
again tell me who stuck out for you guys
potential frontrunner just based off of
our very basic info of where they're
from how old they are how they look you
shouldn't judge a book by it's cover but
the cover is all we've got we don't have
any of the pages when you can't open it
and read it and check out the first page
the last page in the summary and the
introductory note by a fellow author
what are you supposed to go off of when
you can't go online and look at the
reviews and see what everybody else is
saying it's not the New York Times
bestseller list what are you supposed to
do we're walking through an airport
we're stopping at the gift shop all we
see is the covers we're late for our
flight we've got to catch it we should
have left earlier luckily we only out of
carry-on oh we have TSA PreCheck this is
how I operate
I get to the airport very late certain
people in my life who are very important
to me I'm much more prompt than myself
who do you think are talking about
hmmm alright guys that is all the
bachelor news we can booze let me finish
this wine for all the men good luck to
the mole I do want to tell you uppity
online.com right now if you're looking
to get your Bachelor fix filled we have
new interviews with Colton and Cassie
where they talk about getting engaged
soon with Becca and Garrett where they
give us an update on life together in
San Diego and also a new interview with
Arie and Lauren talking about their
babymoon planning to be parents all
these things yes are in line so check it
out a TV online calm and again we will
be here every Tuesday until the bachelor
at premiere one more bit of Bachelor
News weekend booze I wish I had more
wine there's just what we also know the
bachelor in paradise from your date oh
my god the trade never stops and we are
happy to be on it choo choo okay I've
got it I've got it I've got it I'm home
the wings of love and we you're heading
to almost paradise it's premiering on
July 29th almost paradise we got all
season a bachelorette it's gonna be nice
some spice love you guys so much let me
know who your early picks are for Hannah
be in the comments and again
we'll be here every Tuesday with a new
episode roses and Tuesday's I love you
I've missed you so having you back with
you
[Music]